[Music]
right I should probably explain what's
going on now I'm here in Berlin because
I was invited by a group of people that
you have always certainly never heard of
called ren21 ren21 is well I'll let them
explain so ren21
is a multi-stakeholder network we are we
collectively work together to push the
energy transformation with renewables
ren21 is headquartered in Paris with the
United Nations Environment Program which
means this trip kind of feels like
graduating from Model UN to real UN and
they do these academies where they bring
together all these different
stakeholders from the energy industry
from governments and get them to talk to
each other about how we can basically
accelerate the path towards renewable
energy so the moment I am at what feels
very much like an academic conference
look at the view from my room look at
that bridge right we're going out there
what would me today is the second day of
proceedings I didn't vlog yesterday
because I wasn't doing anything active
although kind of wish I have because
everything happened one of the key
organizers had to leave because of an
emergency so everyone's roles changed at
the last minute somebody else's wife
went into labor and so they had to leave
at the last minute we had a bio scare at
the hotel everything was happening now
if you've seen any of my blogs from
conferences before you'll know there's a
pretty standard format right you have a
session talks that lasts for like an
hour and a half as a break there's
another session as lunch and then
eventually there'll be a poster session
we get lots of people normally PhD
students presenting their research on
like an a.1 poster this is different
incidentally the conference is happening
literally just down the road from the
Berlin Wall well this big old chunk at
the Berlin Wall this is the East Side
Gallery where it's been repainted and as
Anna used as an outdoor art gallery I
was born just after this thing came down
I don't think my parents ever would have
imagined I'd be invited by some more
experts to come talk to them in the
shadow of this
understanding what's happening there's a
lot of information there's a lot of
knowledge but it is collected and
processed in different ways by different
parties so part of it is standardizing
it and when I say standardizing it I'm
not I'm not saying to to make it all the
same but in a way that that we can use
it to really understand what is
happening so what is happening on the
investment front why is investment not
happening how can we then start to
address that what is happening on the
policy front
how are those policies being measured
how do you measure an effective policy
are you looking at at the installed
capacity are you looking at it from a
socio-economic perspective they all have
value but it it also makes it different
it also makes it difficult to be able to
have a really clear picture about about
what's happening anyway this conference
is different because yes there have been
talks and have been some very very
interesting speakers actually but the
main component of this conference has
been discussion so the sessions which
took place this morning which I wasn't
taking part in were between these energy
experts we do from industries people
from government people policies all
taking part in discussion but I wouldn't
have the slightest clue as to begin with
compared to what I would consider to be
traditional academic conferences which
basically been science conferences these
questions don't have definite answers
which is why I think the rest there are
as many sessions on posters and talks
because it's not like someone can come
up and say oh this is a problem I've
been working on it yeah this is the
solution you're welcome there is no one
solution to how do we improve renewable
energy uptake in transport
so instead these sessions have been
about instead of producing these
documents at the ends which have been on
display up in the room for this session
which I think was the transport section
all the different sessions are based on
different specific questions and so you
get all these really valuable
perspectives coming together and
actually providing an overall picture
from the top down and the bottom up of
these really complicated problems so
it's a really important thing that's
going on here now I know what you're
thinking Simon
no no not a policymaker you're not an
energy person you are a dynamics guy
you've got a PhD in that was very
physics but it's not a useful wonder
this kind of conference you know what
you're absolutely right so why am I here
my sessions in the afternoon we just
have the last session of the morning
which was bringing everyone back
together again
reporting on conclusions of the previous
sessions we're also looking specifically
at energy in cities so 75% of all
emissions complement to things which
were interesting about that session one
they had a really really cool mic which
was like a box so you just have a whole
new you know pick up like an
omnidirectional mic it was big use of
energy hopefully everybody or another
what do you think about it say you want
to introduce a new way of cooking right
you want it to be energy efficient that
then ties together all the difficulties
that these guys are facing on the panels
it's a technological problem what
technology do you have in order to make
it is gonna be biogas as given solar
what is the legislation are you allowed
to make it are there going to be kind of
subsidies is it are you can be able to
make it cheaper than the current also
fuel alternatives and then if they're
gonna be the infrastructure to develop
it and to deliver for example why I
guess so it's all of these different
factors really brings home like a little
microcosm why these are such difficult
problems okay that's enough academic
stuff I need lunch
which is this way
today there is there is unfortunately
still the perception that renewable
energy it's much more expensive than
fossil fuel and the reality is however
that this is really not the case I mean
the evidence shows that cost-wise
renewable energy in particular solar PV
and wyms are the cheapest electricity
generation with regard to subsidies
actually we do know and this is really
something which is complicated to
calculate but when we are looking to
subsidies for fossil fuel and nuclear
the numbers differ a bit but we still
have three to five times higher
subsidies for fossil fuel than what we
have for renewable energy and when we're
looking for instance in to sella pv and
winds today it is cheaper to invest
until you renewable energy based power
production capacities then continuing
operating existing coal-fired power
plant for instance or gas motors and
this is something that's really a
message which needs to be out there so
academic conferences rise and fall by
the quality of their food
as in as in a vegan enough of it I have
almost certainly puts on a bunch of
weight last year good job Brent 21 the
food was so good so there's an extra
session that's just happening now after
lunch before my session and I just
thought I'd come and introduce you to
all the interns and people all these
people who have declared that they hate
being she was afraid to be on camera I'm
trying to show you that it's time for my
session okay so we're in the middle of
the session that's happening right now
I gave quick little talk I didn't have a
full presentation because basically I'm
battered of my dream ailes deeply I gave
a quick presentation talking basically
not what I do and why I think the the
benefits of blogging are it's all stuff
that people who watch this channel
regularly with apper before if not I did
a TED talk about it but what you see
happening in the background is people
acting on when the other speakers Tom
who was talking about the hero's journey
and basically getting people to think as
storytellers which is what I sort of
another thing that I would love to talk
about he was better than talking about
it anyway but they're developing stories
either about themselves as the hero or
imagining some scenario through example
president that X company decides they
wake up and has to change absolutely
everything to do with energy and how
does that play out and try and basically
make them engaging narrators and
storytellers so it's a really valuable
skill it's a really interesting workshop
and try not to scare people off with the
camera but I definitely want to get some
people on camera later to talk about
what it is that do which is going to go
towards a video that I'm hopefully gonna
be working on roughly when this is
released Fabia why does everyone of this
conference not want to be on camera
Flavia is all serve vlogger and a PhD
student la vía is the reason that I'm
here
you invited you because you watched very
very briefly what is your thesis about
because my audience knows me from the
perspective of like a dynamics
perspective so when I say governance
people are a bit like what are you
talking about how much substance based
because the industry hugely subsidized
Germany the UK there is support that's
why offshore wind is doing so well ocean
is really not so much but the fun thing
that they have in the UK is actually
coming from the European Commission
[Music]
the state of renewable energy in Europe
European Union is that we have 70% 17
1:7 the scent of our energy consumption
is coming from renewable energy if you
compare that to other big regions of
countries in the world this is quite a
fair bit and the European Union had
already has already set a target to have
at least 20 percent in 2020 and it's
looking that we're gonna achieve this
target now only last week the Parliament
agreed on a new proposal which just has
to be ratified by the Member States but
it's you know it's not going to change
that we're going to have 32 percent of
renewable energy by 2030 now that's
quite big especially if you compare it
to the rest of the world in terms of big
countries I mean there are a couple of
countries which have very good resources
like Brazil or Costa Rica etc which have
indeed are able to achieve hundred
percent of renewable energy in certain
sectors or close to hundred percent but
this means that Europe is actually
really said kind of relatively ambitious
herbaceous target for the next 12 years
well today was very interesting if
long-day his conference days tend to
tend to be balancing this new role I
have is like a academic in the sense
that like if this was a dynamics
conference I would want to take part and
you know maybe not you know I would
probably wanna give a poster on my
thesis but also you know listen to all
the discussions but I used to be doing
that whilst like vlogging on the side
now I am primarily at this conference a
videographer and an academic on the site
I'm a recovering academic so this has
been kind of an interesting experience
in that it is familiar but not it's just
just different enough that it feels like
uncharted territory
what's been called has been seeing all
the different stakeholders in energy
actually talking to each other and
seeing the academy accomplishing the
mission which is basically the most
important thing that any group of people
are doing on the planet like actively
trying to move the planet towards a
sustainable future using renewable
energy moving us away from practices
which we know are destructive this kind
of conversation is happening in the
Oh over there is so unbelievably
important and so to see it happening in
real time
like often felt like a real privilege to
be bearing witness to these people
meeting these ideas meeting and you know
decisions being made and path to action
being kind of chalked out for future
policy that's that was really really
awesome see but that is the end of a
very very long day and I need to do some
work tonight because I always need to do
work so I'm gonna end the vlog thank you
very very much for watching thank you to
ren21 for inviting me out here to Berlin
it's a lovely City I definitely just
burped I had a fantastic time whilst I
was here there's another day of the
conference tomorrow but it's only a half
day because I'm going off to somewhere
else which might be a video I don't know
probably not so I'm gonna leave you with
this one day as a conference experience
speaking to these world experts on
energy which was very rewarding I felt
like a privilege to be here and very
very fun atmosphere
thank you for watching i'll see in the
next one
[Music]